this is a piece called playing the
building that I did in collaboration
with a creative time here in New York
we're in the battery maritime building
which is at the very foot of Manhattan
it's a beautiful space I realized that
you could turn the space into a musical
instrument by attaching machines to the
various parts of the structure this
thing is basically a controller it's
just a set of switches that switches
these various machines that are attached
all around the building on and off and
so by doing that to people the public
can come in here and well play the
building negative it turns the whole
building into a kind of musical
instrument if I play some of these like
blows air through various pipes and you
get these kind of food like tones and
then these are electric motors that are
either up there or way down there and
they're attached to the girders that are
that used to support a stained glass
skylight but that's long gone and then
there's a group of keys that switch the
solenoids which are basically just a
little electric things that cause metal
rods just strike various parts of the
building and they hit the column for
radiators or bits of pipe or whatever
it's you get a little pockets of sound
it's about the public coming in and
sitting down at this thing and it turns
the machine and all these wires and
hoses and everything basically turn this
old building into a huge musical
you
[Music]